[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american
supernatural horror film called carrie
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
margaret white is a deluded religious
fanatic who thinks everything is sinful
especially if it is related to women
their bodies and sex in the opening
scene she is on her bloodied bed
screaming in pain and asking god to
forgive her sins she is so unmindful of
the real world that she thinks she is
dying of cancer when in reality she's
just in labor when the pain finally
subsides she looks in between her legs
and freezes in shock to see a newborn
baby girl margaret thinks that the
infant is the result of the sin she
committed with her former husband she
brings out a pair of scissors getting
ready to murder the baby but cannot
bring herself to do it the little girl
is named carrie over the years margaret
forces her religious beliefs on carrie
and doesn't give her any freedom at all
she restricts her from making friends
talking to men and doesn't let her go to
school for most of her life when carrie
turns 16 however children's rights
activists forcefully make margaret let
her daughter go to high school however
because of her anti-social and
introverted nature carrie is always made
fun of she never talks to anyone and
stares in shock when girls show cleavage
or couples kiss the concept of dating is
foreign to her one day while the
students are playing water volleyball
carrie accidentally hits the popular
girl sue in the head sue's friend chris
makes fun of carrie and everyone laughs
at her after the class they go to the
shower room to change carrie gets her
first period while showering and starts
to panic she has never been taught about
periods or anything that has to do with
female anatomy the blood running down
her legs makes her think she is dying of
an illness she runs around frantically
asking the girls for help chris realizes
that carrie doesn't understand what
menstruation is and makes fun of her
soon all the other girls join in and
throw tampons at her while filming her
crying sue feels bad for carrie but
doesn't stop the girls scared to be
declared an outcast like her they only
stop when the gym teacher miss
desjardins arrives there kerry starts
having a panic attack screaming and
crying even after the girls stop to calm
her down the teacher slaps her in the
face as the girls walk away carrie
stares at the light bulb in anger and it
coincidentally shatters when the
principal is informed of the incident he
asks miss desjardins to punish the
bullies as she wishes he also tells
carrie to calm down because they have
called her mother however the thought of
her mother finding out she got her
period makes her even more nervous she
hyperventilates and a water cooler in
the room shatters mysteriously some time
later margaret comes to pick up her
daughter and sees chris and her
boyfriend billy making out she doesn't
want such influence around her daughter
and praise to god to show the spoiled
kids the correct path to life
on the way home carrie asks margaret why
she never taught her about menstruation
but margaret doesn't answer before
getting out of the car a neighbor kid
calls carrie a weirdo she looks at him
and makes him fall off of his bike
similar strange things have been
happening to her for the past few months
and she doesn't know why inside the
house margaret is banging her head
against the wall apologizing to god for
creating her daughter who will someday
sin as she send with her former husband
she even creates fake bible verses to
make carrie believe that bleeding on a
period is a sin and she has become a
sinner carey knows that her mother is
lying because miss desjardins explained
everything about menstruation earlier
she retaliates that it is normal and
every girl gets it this makes margaret
knock her in the head with a bible she
locks her inside a tiny praying closet
telling her to come out only when she
has asked for forgiveness from god
carrie yells in anger which makes the
door crack she then lays eyes on a
sculpture of jesus that starts to bleed
somewhere else sue and her boyfriend
tommy are in tommy's jeep at his request
they make love in the car after getting
dressed sue tells him that she feels
guilty for not helping carrie in the
shower room meanwhile chris is with her
boyfriend billy at her house unlike sue
she shows no regret whatsoever even
though she was the one who initiated the
bullying to humiliate carrie even more
she uploads the video of the incident to
the internet back in the house margaret
is calmly sewing clothes while singing
songs it is almost as if she has
forgotten about what happened earlier
with her daughter she eventually lets
carrie out of the closet after
confirming that she prayed to god the
next day at school miss desjardins
gathers chris sue along with all the
other girls who were involved as a
punishment they will have to do suicide
sprints for an hour every day for the
rest of the week anyone who disobeys
will be denied access to the upcoming
prom chris calls the punishment [ __ ]
and challenges miss desjardins to make
her stop from coming to prom an enraged
miss desjardins suspends her and revokes
her prom privileges chris protests and
tries to rally the other girls to join
her but no one supports her not even her
best friend sue in the meantime the
entire school has watched the video of
carrie getting bullied they make fun of
her and even go as far as to spray
graffiti on her locker that says carrie
white eats [ __ ] the bullies in these
movies are never clever humiliated and
filled with rage she goes to the
bathroom and concentrates on the mirror
which shatters because of her stare
carrie finally begins to realize she has
the power of psychokinesis which means
she can move objects and people using
only her mind to learn more about her
power she goes to the library and reads
several books about psychokinesis the
report on it makes her believe that like
menstruation having such power is also
normal for some people in the next class
she is called to the front of the
classroom to read a poem when she is
done sue's boyfriend tommy mutters an
insult under his breath but when asked
to speak louder he claims that carrie's
poem was awesome carrie is shocked and
shy that a guy complimented her
meanwhile chris calls her lawyer father
to the school to try and overturn her
revoked prom privileges she plays the
victim accusing miss desjardins of
verbally abusing her to prove her wrong
miss dejardin asks for her phone that
has the video of her bullying carrie
however chris refuses to hand it over
proving that she is guilty that night
carrie tests her power by levitating
books and her bed margaret hears a noise
and comes upstairs with a knife to
investigate by then carrie is pretending
to sleep so she puts the knife down the
next day sue asks her boyfriend tommy to
take carey to the prom she believes that
carrie deserves one night of fun and is
ready to miss out on senior prom for her
tommy wants to go with sue but on being
insisted repeatedly he agrees then he
walks up to carrie and asks her out to
prom a surprised carrie thinks he is
pranking her and runs away later miss
desjardins finds her crying in the
locker room when asked what is wrong
carrie tells her about tommy's proposal
the teacher supports carrie but she also
knows that tommy thinks of her as an
outcast she finds sue and tommy and
warns them to rethink it if they are
planning to humiliate carrie after
school tommy drives to carrie's house
much to her horror because she doesn't
want her mother to know she talks to
boys he declares that he will only leave
if she agrees to go to prom with him
carrie says yes but under the condition
that he will bring her home by 10 30 pm
she is excited to finally be like the
rest of the kids to prepare for prom she
goes shopping but none of the dresses
are under her budget so instead she buys
fabric to sell one herself chris sees
carrie shopping and is filled with rage
she along with her friends plan to play
a prank on her at prom upon returning
home carrie finds an angry margaret
waiting for her she tells her mother
that she is going to prom but margaret
declares she won't allow her carey grows
frustrated and levitates things to
release her anger margaret prays to god
assuming that the devil has taken over
her daughter carrie asks her to stop
talking but margaret prays even louder
eventually carrie makes her mother
levitate making her go quiet she
releases her a while later declaring
that the conversation is over meanwhile
chris and billy are at a farm with their
group of friends they collect blood by
slitting a pig's throat then they break
into the gymnasium which is also the
prom venue they rig a pail with the pig
blood intending to dump it on carrie
when she is on stage on prom night
carrie gets ready and applies light
makeup she looks stunning but is very
nervous margaret asks her to dress
modestly but carrie doesn't bother
arguing with her margaret tells her
daughter that everyone is going to laugh
at her which makes carrie more nervous
than she already is she locks her mother
in the praying closet before making her
way out tommy is speechless when he sees
her they go to the prom hand in hand and
tommy introduces her to his friends miss
desjardins also compliments her dress
and asks her to have fun with time she
loosens up and feels much more
comfortable around tommy a while later
the two slow dance together the night
cannot get any better for carrie but
then billy and chris break into the
venue they wait under the temporary
stage to execute their plan they have
rigged the prom king and queen election
to ensure that carrie and tommy are
elected when the couple climbs to the
stage to receive the awards they will
drop the bucket of blood on kerry before
the election chris sends sue a text that
says they are about to humiliate carrie
a horrified sioux races to the prom to
stop her soon tommy and carrie win the
titles of prom king and queen they are
called to the stage as everyone applauds
for them sue also gets to the building
and sees chris and the rafters seconds
away from dumping the blood on carrie
miss desjardins sees sue and thinks she
is here to ruin the moment so she locks
her inside a room without listening to
what she has to say at last chris pulls
the rope dumping the blood on carrie she
also hacks the monitor and plays the
video from the day she got her period
everyone laughs as miss dejardin comes
forward to help her but by now carrie
has lost all rationality she pushes miss
desjardins back without touching her and
everyone gasps seconds later the pail
falls on tommy's head killing him
instantly carrie loses control of her
power and pushes the crowd away with a
single scream chris and billy manage to
escape and get in their car however when
the others try to run outside carrie
locks all the doors and windows next she
throws the tables and chairs at the
crowd killing them one by one she also
holds some girls to the ground so they
are killed after being trampled the
place lights on fire when she breaks the
stage lights and electrical wires she
puts miss desjardins safely on the stage
but finishes off the rest of the crowd
she then flies outside looking for billy
and chris they drive away in their car
but are chased by carrie billy tries to
run her over but carrie stops the car
with her power causing him to hit his
head and die instantly chris tries to
run over her again but carrie launches
the vehicle into a gas station she then
watches as chris dies slowly stuck to
the windshield following that she goes
home and notices her mother isn't in the
praying closet she bathes to clean off
all the blood margaret finally appears
in front of her and carrie hugs her
mother claiming that she was right about
everyone making fun of her margaret
still thinks that she is being punished
for sinning with her husband and stabs
carrie with a butcher knife carrie tries
to save herself but margaret goes into a
frenzy and chases her into the kitchen
she pins carrie down and is about to
stab her again but carrie uses her power
to stop her she sends several sharp
objects towards margaret crucifying her
then she cries holding her dying mother
and regretting what she did at last she
uses her power to destroy the house just
then sue arrives at the house and tries
to stop carrie she is about to kill her
as well but halt after realizing sue is
pregnant carrie smiles and claims that
it is a girl she sends sue outside to
save her from the falling ceiling
moments later margaret and carrie die
under the collapsing house some months
later sue is in the hospital bed
screaming in pain while giving birth
suddenly a bloodied hand emerges from
her and she wakes up realizing it was
just a dream her mother comforts her and
she hyperventilates thinking that she is
about to give birth
to carrie
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching